question how much of this is all gonna
be public like if I write in there about
my deepest darkest fantasies will this
be displayed to the people of YouTube
so I was thinking about my first time
journaling and I was in sixth grade and
I'd written this journal and my friends
found the journal and read it out loud
and laughed at me so I threw the journal
in the trash
I kept several journals as a child I
would write who my crush was and what I
wanted to do to my enemy I'm coming in
as a grown woman with no journaling
experience I had this rad Ferrari
notebook and like every other journal
I've ever had I did about three entries
and then that was the last entry kind of
hoping that maybe at least fill up half
the book I'm excited to journal because
this is gonna be retribution for my
stolen journal when I was abroad in
college okay it's journal time I'm in my
bedroom
there's my journal it's happening I'm
hanging out in the back of my minivan
and I'm about to do my first entry in my
journal so far it's been kind of tough
cuz I'm out of practice my hand hurts
and I'm not exactly sure what I'm
supposed to be writing about
I have usually been journaling so far in
the evenings in my dining room which is
where I am now I've been doing that well
I'm gonna be honest I spend way too much
time sitting there going I should be
journaling I should be journaling don't
you guys see that
oh it just comes out it's like word
vomit for me and drawing vomit I'm just
like all over the place in this thing
and then my cat plays with this string
and it's so cute amazing at first I was
like what do I want to write about what
I might and then it's just kind of like
coming out of me
I mean it is interesting to have a
journal which feels like the offline
like most inner thoughts versus like all
the social media that I work in to me it
seems like Instagram and Twitter and all
of those things are such a carefully
architectured version of how someone
wants to present their life and
journaling is essentially at least for
me about the messy complicated not so
sudden any thoughts you know Hillary got
that Journal
versus Instagram thing in my head and I
haven't stopped thinking about that and
she's totally right it's very it's very
introspective journaling is the opposite
of Instagram and I've never journaled
before and I definitely Instagram before
and it's interesting to do both in the
same day I'm a journal at heart it's
just a way to create everyday in some
type of way when did you stop dancing
when did you stop singing when did you
stop being enchanted by stories when did
you stop finding comfort in the sweet
territory of silence I think the
question I would ask myself is when did
you stop creating I'm enjoying it's kind
of just taking this time for myself
every day so I've been journaling a lot
in my van parks places I like to do it
cuz new environment is kind of inspiring
my boyfriend is recording with his band
right now and I'm doodling in my journal
it's really fun to draw and write my
journal while I'm around so I think I'm
getting a little bit better at this
journaling thing I've realized I can
write down the weird dreams that I have
about Tina Fey I've been trying to have
a little bit more fun with the journal
and do drawings and stuff but it also
just feels like a chore all the time
just like my nightly homework assignment
draw and journal
this one I think you'll all enjoy I am
so over writing in this damn book all
the time
I quit so not that into journaling what
are your reasons you don't like it Irene
uh thing important it's like I bought a
projector today let's see how I like it
I've been trying to figure out the best
way to set it up I need a screen that
like that's why did I write that down
you know in retrospect I wish I'd have
hired a journaling ghostwriter I think
the number one thing I learned I don't
want to journal too like reflect on my
life I think it's more fun to talk about
silly weird stuff
red ink red book red shorts I was
writing this well wearing red shorts
with a red pen in a red books I was
really excited about that I realized
that being looser really allowed me to
have more fun with it instead of going
through Instagram or going on Twitter or
whatever I would doodle in my journal
for a second and I liked that a lot I
learned there's a reason I haven't been
journaling for so many years cuz like
journaling is not my faith I think my
big takeaway is that journal you should
be used as a sketch pad for your ideas
and your thoughts and a place to let
your mind wander
I feel like there'll be another period
after this where it'll make sense to
journal again well I love that my cat
loves the string that's like my favorite
thing ever my cat loves journaling just
as much as I do
you